where'd you get the wig and dress i made
it
we thought wigs were only used for heads
but hollywood proved us wrong
we were shocked to learn cara de levine
were a very particular type of wig for
one of her films
from hiding balding to protecting hair
extremely damaged by bleach
we were surprised by so many of these
actors who wore wigs in films
what were they hiding i didn't have time
to grow my hair
so we had this like pelt tom holland
totally shocked fans when he chopped off
these beautiful locks for his role in
the film cherry
though what surprised us even more was
seeing this wig on him in the same movie
it's definitely a different look but the
transition is pretty seamless
when he got back to filming for the new
spider-man the plan was to put him in
some hair pieces to bring him back to
his spidey looks
holland surprisingly refused and opted
to keep his natural hair for the movie
instead
wow she looks pretty
pretty much everyone loved millie bobby
brown sporting her new long and curly
locks in enola homes
this style really suited her but in
reality it was all a wig
it was a very different experience for
her since the last major hair
transformation she went through was
shaving all her hair for stranger things
except for those times 11 wore this
terrible blonde wig
we definitely don't miss that that's
edward cullen
it's totally gorgeous obviously robert
pattinson had a
bit of a diva moment when it came to
shooting twilight originally he was
meant to have hair extensions to achieve
a more
timeless look but pattinson hated them
so much he
literally ripped them out of his head so
they went with this wig instead which
was actually
five different wigs and hair pieces put
together oh the hair drama
seven years ago i had my
kidney transplant we were so surprised
to learn the reason that sarah hyland
was wearing extensions
and hair pieces for much of the modern
family series hyland suffers from
endometriosis and kidney dysplasia for
which she's had to get
16 surgeries including two kidney
transplants
all the treatments she had resulted in
quite a bit of hair loss so to keep her
looking like the halo we all knew
hair extensions and editions did the
trick i'm gonna come back
only better this time catherine heigl
has played tons of iconic blonde
characters over the years
so her role as the brunette tully and
firefly lane was definitely surprising
but just as iconic at first we thought
maybe she dyed her hair
after all she did rock the brunette look
in one for the money
however looking at her instagram it
appears that she's still a blonde and
indeed actually wearing a wig for
firefly lane
since her hairstyles throughout the
different decades do vary quite a bit
her wearing wigs definitely make sense
for ease of transition
when ashley benson played hannah in
pretty little liars she bleached her
hair regularly to achieve this signature
blonde look
after a few seasons warner brothers
contacted her and said something needed
to be done because her damaged hair was
becoming
extremely noticeable she wound up using
a wig instead and fortunately was able
to prevent her hair from being harmed
anymore
it was a really great match since we
never even noticed the difference while
some wigs and stranger things were
obvious
q11's blonde mess we were shocked to
learn that nearly every actor had a wig
for the show
this included david harbour with his 80s
style do
it looks very natural but in real life
his hair isn't quite as full as his
characters is
yeah and then it gives her a little bit
oh go down faithfully
we have never heard of an armpit wig
before but
it turns out they exist that's right
cara de levine had laser hair removal
done on her underarms
assuming she'd never really be required
to have hair there again
but she was so very wrong her role in
the film her smell
required a grungy looking vibe so these
armpit wigs were created for her
using ventilated lace wigs my hair grows
to here and then it goes nah
we're good we're gonna stop now rachel
mcadams was pretty smart when she was
cast as regina george in refusing to
bleach her hair
maybe she researched it and knew how
many actors had terrible experiences
with it
instead this gorgeous hair she had was a
wig entirely made of human hair
it makes sense why it looks so realistic
he got a haircut
that's sexy hot krazynski shares the
sneakiness trait with his character jim
on the office
when season 3 of the office rolled
around he was cast in the george clooney
film leather heads
and we can see that his hair is pretty
far from jim's signature floppy locks
the production didn't want him to cut
his hair so krazynski wound up asking
the hair stylist for the office to make
him a wig in secret
he went on to have a full conversation
with showrunner greg daniels in the wig
to prove that it wouldn't be noticeable
and
well he managed to pass the test costume
and hair makeup it all changes and
along with all of the tatiana maslany
clones in orphan black came
a multitude of impressively realistic
looking wigs
we knew some of the wigs especially
these blonde ones were fake
but even the most natural looking ones
we see here were all wigs
every single character from the twisted
look to the natural waves
had some of the most impressive real
looking hair we've ever seen on screen
you shrunk five inches oh my god you'll
be able to wear heels tonight
emma stone's hair wasn't too different
in terms of color and
curling here definitely isn't out of the
ordinary for films
what was more shocking to learn is that
these two styles are actually
two different wigs they definitely
fooled us though
i'm not a ginger i'm a dirty dirty
blonde sam hewitt is a natural blonde
but the actor did dye his hair red for
his role on outlander
however the dying didn't end up working
out so well so wigs came to the rescue
even though they ended up being better
than dying hair for six months of the
year
he was not a fan of the wig either and
said that it was so uncomfortable to
shoot in
it actually felt like torture the wig
didn't take too long my hair is a wig
the mullet is cringy we know but
it's shockingly realistic even the crew
didn't realize that the hair on the side
of his head was all part of a wig
watching his wild audition tape for the
show made us believe that the mullet
definitely could have been his own
absurd creation
what you look nice
there could probably be a video done
just on the evolution of hugh jackman's
wolverine hair
the first time he played the role well
let's just say he looks like he could be
related to john travolta
when we see him in x-men days of future
past we can see that his hair looks a
bit more natural but
guess what it's still a wig to hide his
balding
you're very good people enjoy your work
you know oscar nominations and all that
why have we never really seen michelle
williams rock her gorgeous pixie cut in
a movie
only one of her last 10 movies had her
appearing without a wig
these long blonde locks she wore in i
feel pretty really did transform her
it's sad to say that the reason she is
rarely sporting the pixie cut is because
of the stereotypical expectations of
beauty in hollywood
what's with the outfit sudden chills
and light sensitivity when we think of
house we can definitely imagine him with
or without a lot of hair as it doesn't
really have much of an effect on the
character however
hugh laurie did indeed wear a hair piece
to fill out his do on the show
seeing him off screen we can definitely
notice a very obvious bald spot
and thinning hair he doesn't seem like a
particularly vain actor so
it's a bit of a mystery as to why he had
a hairpiece at all
that's what i got i was losing my hair
in 99. no
yes i was it's not news that mcconaughey
wears wigs regularly in film since he
started losing hair quite young but we
were shocked to learn that even in
interstellar arguably his least glam
role
he had a hair piece it's subtle but
definitely there
look at this guy does it seem like he
shouldn't be balding
it could probably go either way but
maybe mccon hay is just used to it now
how cute are you
can we oh that's like with my braces and
my my uh haircut that was inspired by
duran duran
do we stand gabrielle union and her
gorgeous hair
yes yes we do however it is sensitive so
in order to avoid too much heat and
treatment
union manages to pull off wigs in tons
of her rolls we have to say that this
wig and bring it on is one of the best
for sure
look how natural it looks it definitely
suits her well
although she does look good in pretty
much any hairstyle
carrie washington is a total boston
scandal
and so is her hair her wigs on the show
are so good we had a hard time telling
when she was wearing one and when she
wasn't
like when she was kidnapped in this
episode the wigs actually say a lot
about the reality many black women face
in the world since so often their
natural hair isn't considered
professional enough for the workplace
the reasons for these actors wearing
wigs are so varied but
all of them shockingly convincing the
hollywood hairstylists
definitely deserve a raise for pulling
off such strong looks to help actors
hide their true locks
did you realize almost every single
stranger things actor was wearing a wig